just stare creepily for a while hey man
it is Friday
[ __ ] night in what used to be
Hollywood
so let's babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin no
that's the wrong show oh my god
it's Friday night yeah that's the way I
start that show welcome to fat man
beyond thank you
I'm Kevin Spence I'm mark barnard
yelling hey I get them confused thanks
for hanging out ladies gentlemen on a
Friday night as you can see the place is
jumpin I could barely hear each other oh
man it's just these we were filling up
the space like you wouldn't believe
marques you see has become the chief of
police and the Watchmen TV series I
didn't realize we were cosplaying no I
would have brought a you know a fun TV
show mask as well I mean I found myself
in need of a face mask slash bandana is
that did you take a yellow shirt and cut
it up no I I was always on the Internet
which is all I have left to do right and
aren't we all
yeah I was on Damon Lindelof Instagram
page holy [ __ ] look out everybody the
names are dropping they're dropping my
names are dropping and and so he was
wearing one of these and I was like oh
[ __ ] dude I would like one of those too
and then like yesterday I get this red
envelope shows up of my house
addressed to me from the from the
Redford administration and if you know
the Watchmen series from HBO you know
what that means that's resident and
inside make president wears this mask
and a little note saying that yeah this
is this is an authentic we made these
for the Watchmen show sort of a yellow
face mask and was like well [ __ ] it I
gotta wear it on my comic book program
one percenter story about [ __ ] a man
I just told Damon give me something in
Dave
that's pretty dope man so you're wearing
a legit movie prop legit TV series proud
it is not screen used until right this
very moment [ __ ] a so they didn't have
to worship like it didn't belong to John
Johnson I don't believe so
I don't bless oh how do I know give us
Damon's address so we could all get
[Laughter]
massaman Linda beautiful they're welcome
folks hopefully you've been having a you
know a peaceful time at home hopefully
the coronavirus hasn't affected you
directly and if it has or someone you
know and love and whatnot hopefully
they're pulling through weird crazy time
it is definitely a weird time to be
talking about the nonsense that we talk
about except that so all we got kids how
much more nonsense will there like
sooner or later the nonsense is gonna
run out right like I assume we're
rolling on stockpiled nonsense of the
last couple months but like as
businesses ground to a halt won't sooner
or later there be like nonsense yeah
there's like literally nothing to talk
about
like nothing new has happened I know I
mean its segments are the business of
grind to a halt I mean clearly
production is stopped everybody's in
their houses sheltering and staying in
place hmm pitches are still happening
it's true have you been pitching I
haven't been pitching but I have a bunch
of friends who have been and just we're
doing zoom pitches video conference
pitches I'm with you I pitched recently
via zoom and it was it was an
interesting experience I don't ever want
to go back to the other way because I
was telling Ralph today if you're you
know like hey you gotta go pitch in
Santa Monica and you're like oh man
Santa Monica is like far you shower you
get dressed Drive all the way Santa
Monica it takes like an hour and shift
you get there you give your pitch nine
and a half times out of ten it's a no so
then you got to drive all the way
[ __ ] back and you're like man I mean
I know it's a first world problem but
still being on Zoom you know if I'm like
good morning
and I just rolled out of bed so this is
the show where they're gonna do and
they're like we don't like that I'm like
I no harm no foul and you're going
backward do your day man it's none of
this driving and [ __ ] like that no no
harsh feelings about the people you've
pitched to so I like it I hope that that
sticks around after everybody eventually
goes back to work which won't be
happening here anytime soon they just
extended was that just California or the
whole nation
it was Jim's to be a state-by-state
basis because there are still a handle
of states that are not sheltering at
home at all which ones are those I would
say like Iowa was one Florida seems to
be on the fence back and forth Ken Damon
send them all masks please
they're jumping on very late to the game
yeah but it's it's a California stay at
home order until May 15 right
I think LAUSD has already called the
school year so at least kids in
California will be doing the balance of
their schooling this year at home is
that right it's done school's out for
2020 because I think that even wants to
stay at home you know order lifts kids
who's gonna want to send their kid yeah
it's still gonna be are you I'll tell
you who's gonna want to send their kid
every [ __ ] parent who's like I just
been cooped up in this kid for two
[ __ ] months I you could send him to
like [ __ ] what's that bad school
where they send kids the form school
Jimmy said let's get the [ __ ] over
Sunnydale high yeah every big bad
happens it's any day like that's true
but yeah so so the businesses is kind of
operating pitches are happening a bunch
of virtual writers rooms are up and
running so the the writing on shows can
still happen mm-hmm for example you're a
writer on a show I'm a writer on the
show have you been working on that said
show I have been like you know every day
every other day you know we'll meet in
the zoom room it's a zoom room day and
we'll be doing that for you know a
couple of hours sometimes twice a day
it's fun that it rhymes it is I know
we're in a zoom where it happens zoom
room zoom room but yeah I think that
that there's at some point the the train
will stop it will stop having new news
but the business hasn't entirely stopped
yet hmm like him there's still some
stuff I mean I I was able where we were
able to pull together a bunch of [ __ ]
news but it was not a couple together I
I actually I had a pitch the other day
that like moved the ball forward on
something like where I was like holy
[ __ ] if we're ever allowed to go outside
again I might be able to go back to work
and stuff so that was rather exciting
that's too early to talk about it but
like that was that was kind of kind of
sweet yeah it's I guess if you could
pull together a bunch of stories yeah I
mean these stories that our world still
slowly turning yeah and the stories are
not a thing that you love is not coming
out for another year and a half which
that seems to be the steady drumbeat of
oh you know that thing you wanted to do
can't do it right still gonna happen
just not yet the you know it seems like
the whole broadcast world is adapting
and whatnot everybody's shooting their
shows at home and I saw that SNL is
doing an at-home show like the first in
their history of course yeah so
everybody on [ __ ] zoom and they're
gonna shoot the show I mean it's smart
it's it's everybody cheap too cheap as
hell like every every news organization
is shifted to our anchors are all at
home and whatever and now SNL is doing
that I think all rise a show on CBS is
actually doing they did they're doing a
sort of a pandemic zoom episode whatever
they're the first show that's actually
gonna address the Panda yeah like we're
gonna write although I was I was so
weird I was writing today then I was
working on a twilight of the mall rats
the mall rats to script and so I I had
just read last night articles about the
retail apocalypse where 2020 was going
to be the death knell for a bunch of
stores anyway but the pandemic has
escalated that made it worse and we're
about to see a lot of big-box stores big
name stores that you and I have known
for most of our lives just go away
forever
that means massive vacancies in malls so
they're predicting the implosion the
tire the entire implosion of malls I
mean they were already teetering but in
the entire implosion of malls across
America
so as a guy who's writing a mall movie
set in a mall Mike well that's useful
information my line of work so I had to
start writing the pandemic into the
movie because clearly this is going to
be remembered for all time like it's not
like oh why would you make a that's so
like topical the coronavirus happened
last year you'll still be here in Corona
related stories and plot lines and drops
for the next five to ten years the same
way post September 11th that was
everywhere I can't imagine that you as I
mean well you're dealing in space right
like in Picard world is there any sort
of like we got to mention kovat like as
an earth piece of Earth history
no no thus far no but like I think we
talked about it last time the trying to
figure out how we will be our lives will
be impacted on a long-term basis not and
not specifically the people who like
lost somebody during the pandemic in the
same way not specifically people who
lost somebody during 9/11 mm-hmm but how
the culture changes you know I was
talking to somebody online the other day
and I was like do you actually think
that like professional sports come back
like hey everybody we can play hockey or
baseball or basketball do you think
people are gonna show up and fill those
arenas anymore
like that's 60,000 people sitting on
each other's laps all the time yeah how
quickly do you think people are gonna
get to a point where they're cool with
that pouchy talking about like maybe we
just stop shaking hands for the rest of
our lives and I was like that would be
[ __ ] new yeah that would be a crazy
[ __ ] do you like hug you used to give
somebody to say hello the pound or the
gap or whatever like all of this goes
away just tell you you know who's
talking ahead of the curve [ __ ] Howie
Mandel all this time everyone's been
making fun of like Oh Howie Mandel he's
one of the only does this [ __ ] right now
him Howie Mandel is like told you you
should have listened or he'd be like I
was bad Bobby as bad
he rips off his glove and he puts it
over his head genius old school pool we
are here at our home away from home
ladies gentlemen the scum and villainy
cantina which JC and Jen opened a long
ago three years ago man but it started
as a pop out pop up bar was only meant
to be for the summertime and then
goddamn it
one day JC and Jen were like hey man
this works let's [ __ ] go for it and
they turned it into an ongoing concern
it's been our [ __ ] home the largesse
of them owning a bar gives us a place to
do this show a show that like gets
quoted and misquoted all over the world
and you know we're not even misquoted so
much as I'll go like hey man I've read
like online without even crediting like
I read in Newsweek or so I'm like I just
read some Rando said that daredevil
might be in in Spiderman fact yeah and
people like where'd you get that I'm
like like from the Rando online you
could please everybody
so it's you know because of their large
yes we get to do something fun all the
time and built a thing and and that
thing allows us it gives us certain
credibility in the world and whatnot
keeps one of us [ __ ] relevant it's
it's great it's great good to be
involved with the bar and and all this
time now of course the bar has been hit
hard because the rent here is [ __ ]
astounding I mean we're on Hollywood
Boulevard in Hollywood so it's not a
[ __ ] cheap place these kids you know
add themselves a nest egg ship and
nobody prepared for what happened and
what's still going to continue to happen
for a while and so people been very good
about buying gift certificates for scum
and villainy for when they do open bag
up and stuff like that that helps them
like pay their bills in the interim for
the time being so today's show we're
doing as a fundraiser for
were scum and villainy and what we're
gonna do is I guess you can donate do
you know how this works there's buttons
somewhere I think there's a JC did it
the other day what what it what do they
I got a do JC there holy [ __ ] out
tell him JC anything zone taking that
voice of God very seriously that's
sounds so sexy man like I like that
there's there's a donate link at the top
of the screen that people can use to
donate so you actually have to type it
in there it is
so you can donate to scum and villainy
canteen and because we're like [ __ ]
celebrities we're telling you to do it
and we won't do it ourselves
no of course what we're going to do is
whatever we raise tonight we're gonna
match so whatever you guys throw to the
bar we're gonna match that so let's
raise a few shekels for this home away
from home for all of us
for those of you who have been here you
know special places for those of you
who've only seen it online and dreamed
about coming here we would like you to
be able to do that so let's help out our
friends when we can and right now is the
time so for the first time ever we're
singing for our [ __ ] sutlers I know
right in the room and [ __ ] normally but
like streaming wise like yeah I mean
it's like we're cam cam boys right now
yeah we are we want to hear those we
want to hear those tips it in the jar
ladies and gentlemen yeah [ __ ] he'll
go solo
I've been solo so long so solo ah what
do you been doing in your time aside
from an Italian man it's been a [ __ ]
struggle like I in the beginning I was a
cop I get so much writing done but this
is my like schedule I wake up early 6 7
o'clock and [ __ ] go to my office like my
first joint and I'm like all right
before I dive into my script I might as
well look at the news and see if
anything's changed then it's 4 o'clock
and I haven't written anything and I've
just been in this constant [ __ ] news
spiral and [ __ ] like that it's
I have to be able to show more
discipline I'm very frustrated with
myself for the complete and utter lack
of discipline that I'm showing I
remember post heart attack I was so
[ __ ] disciplined and [ __ ] because I
was like scared for my life I should be
as disciplined now I should really just
wake up ignore the [ __ ] news all
together go right into my script today
let me push the ball forward a little
bit wrote five pages because I was just
refining the first 60 pages of Mallrats
over and over and over again
finally I move forward start writing
some new [ __ ] stuff I can see the end
of the second act like nearby and [ __ ]
so that's good but I have to I have to
[ __ ] display more discipline than I'm
showing because in my head I'm like well
all-time doesn't matter anymore and they
keep extending the quarantine like you
know what do you what are you rushing
for like ease up and [ __ ] but it's I'm
telling you like I'm so frustrated with
myself I have to stop I'm gonna like I
gotta break that chain of interacting
with the news because I'm be honest with
you there's nothing I wouldn't learn you
know by waiting a week like this is this
is like you know clock watches reminds
me of post September 11th when we all
sat in front of the TV and [ __ ]
literally just watched the news 24/7
waiting for like more updates what about
this did they did they say anything new
so I got to break this that's why I like
tonight even I was like at five o'clock
I was like you know what maybe like
we'll put this off and [ __ ] like that
and I was like no [ __ ] goddamn it
like discipline like just [ __ ] like
do something productive so I I'm it's
been a bit of a struggle for me that
oddly enough and it's frustrating how
about you I am in the same place a guy
when when lockdown started when
quarantine II began it's like alright
well hey okay I don't have to go to the
office every day and I have this time to
myself and give a signal I'm gonna go
grab a drink yeah and like and my
family's been really good about just
sort of giving me the space like you've
got to go work and you and your place
where you work so I did and I was
getting almost nothing done I was really
I was able
I was able to do stuff on existing
project right like I was able to give
notes on a pass of this I was able to
execute some notes on the script of my
own I was able to - just like you said
kind of circle the same thing again
right we're fine and tweaked and and
what-have-you but the breaking new
ground on things that I hoped I was
gonna get to do has been incredibly
difficult and I beat myself up about it
for the first week or so until I
remembered that much like September 11th
like this is trauma like this is this is
national trauma this is the world is
different in a way that we didn't expect
it to be and it's gonna take time for
everybody to find a way to process that
trauma and then let yourself move I mean
and I have never had a heart attack so I
don't know what that feels like but
that's a personal trauma that's a like
my body gave up on me we fixed it I'm
healing let's go
as opposed to every time you look
outside every time you are encountered
anything and we commercial you see on TV
is now talking about like contactless
delivery and would you like to buy a car
hey we're gonna defer payments for 126
all one of those commercials you were
the log to your house I saw that I was
like wow man like but they gotta move
merchandise they gotta move merchandise
and like the world will not never let
you forget what's happening outside and
so it's it is not like I remember very
early on so kingly King Lear was written
by Shakespeare during a quarantine of
the plague and it's like you know the
pressure to have to be Shakespeare at
this time like take the time you need
like if you gotta just cope if you got
to watch lots of [ __ ] reruns every
show you've already seen like I'm I'm in
my nostalgia meter is really high
because it's all about like finding
comfort in the familiar like I want to
like eat foods I'm doing this burger
challenge with my son I saw that's
adorable
yeah and it's super fun but again it's
we're just eating hamburgers and
hamburgers we've already eaten before
but it's this like let's gamify
nostalgia and familiarity and I'm just
keep watching it [ __ ] the West Wing
because it's my happy place I could
watch the dozen shows I haven't seen
before
but I'm not good enough like I've been
we've also taken something every night
we'll all get together as a family like
watch a movie that my son has never seen
before mmm and it's it's been wonderful
in fact
but I'm not seeing anything new I'm
showing him things that are new but I
love and think that are good and so I am
acutely aware of the fact that I'm
turning inwards as opposed to outwards
and I'm hoping that I can adjust to that
new sort of water level at some point if
it's next week great if it's next month
we're gonna be here great and then start
to do the new things and start to break
some new ground and start to actually
find myself again because that's been
the weirdest thing is that I just I
can't I can't do the thing that I do
which is tell stories right because I'm
in the middle of a story that I don't
like I can't get out and you don't even
know I was gonna don't know how it's
gonna end
so I think you know frustration is I
feel that for sure but I'm trying not to
beat myself up about it because it's
it's a process and few of us have ever
had to actually try and be productive
during this process because as bad as
9/11 was it was a day at an awful day
but a day and then it was like months
weeks days weeks months years of
aftermath and fallout but it's not like
every week they were like here's another
September 11th totally with this it's
like every day they're like we've just
seen the highest death toll no wait it's
higher to that like every day the story
keeps developing and stuff yeah yeah
it's it's alright and I feel awful for I
mean lots of people especially people
who you know have family members or
friends or whoever themselves or
recovering or succumbing to to the
coronavirus but I also feel bad for
people like you know my wife's birthday
is in like a week and it's a big one and
we're gonna like I'm gonna make dinner
and it's gonna be great but it's not the
oh we would have gone to Hawaii on this
birthday on an ordinary year like my son
is turning 16 in June and it's like
buddy I don't know if you're gonna get
to have a party in June yeah you know
seniors who are graduating aren't gonna
get to walk until like August maybe yeah
you know like just these these massive
milestones and lives of this particular
year are kind of getting pushed off
or cancelled or replaced by some other
version of that Mouse down what year was
the Great Depression what part of the
20s or was that even the 20s it was at
29 29 so is the end this 20s is a
[ __ ] of a decade no matter what the
century right the [ __ ] teeth every
time by the Lord then again the 20s were
also the [ __ ] Jazz Age they were
roaring and they were roaring the robbed
yeah something I mean that's thing
where's the sometimes easy to be like
the to him in the gloom but you know
something good is gonna come out of this
I know it's the you know everyone likes
to be like hey Shakespeare wrote blah
blah blah but you know it is giving
people a lot of time to write just say
it's so weird like like I've been
working on masters in the universe but
that is circling back over stuff that's
done like I saw the two animatics four
episodes one two the [ __ ] astounding
but I was like oh my god I'll I can
write in some more dialogue so like you
know I wrote in another like page
dialogue to throw in while fights are
going on and stuff then not a full page
in a fight but like here line here line
there and stuff but that's just kind of
circling back over work that's been done
you can feel productive but it's
breaking new ground man where I'm like
take it take it forward that's that's
what I'm gonna spend the next week doing
just taking my head out of the news
putting my head into my fake [ __ ]
mall the have you been watchin [ __ ] I
have been watching some [ __ ] man I mean
and a lot of it has been the sort of the
the movie education for my son of the
things that I love that he hasn't seen
yet and seeing how it either survives or
translates like do you think you're
getting more time like stolen time with
your kid now totally like cuz otherwise
you'd be at the office and he'd be
[ __ ] life in school but it's actually
like kind of nice in the midst of all
this maybe the [ __ ] silver lining is a
return to never know the return to the
family but a reinvention of the family
because the family was you
to be going in five different directions
at once and now we're all forced
together under one roof there was no
we're not all having dinner tonight
because where are you gonna be yeah
where are you gonna go you know the the
the pressure now is how do I get him off
of his phone or his laptop or video
games or whatever it's not that hard cuz
it's like I still own the house but
still is mine I'll turn that [ __ ] off
get in here I know the why for watching
Roger Rabbit giant Wi-Fi squid but it's
great you know and like every night
we're going to be sitting together for a
couple of hours be a dinner or like game
night and play some games we're gonna
watch a movie
I'll watch Tiger king let you seen Tiger
Kane course that's crazy right a man
it's it is fascinating it's it's just
it's it's like The Simpsons but there
are no cartoons everybody is a real
human being
larger-than-life crazy did you have you
seen little fires everywhere yeah no
it's good it's totally utterly watchable
yeah I mean yes it's good yes well made
well acted Baba but it's like you know
unlike Pretty Little Liars it's it's
just it's a nighttime soap like as I
watch it I'm like oh this is like it's
literally a soap opera but it's just
that night and not like Knott's landing
or Dallas and [ __ ] like that or dynasty
from back in the day but just kind of
like people relating in the suburbs
we're not relating but they did this
thing where is Rees Witherspoon and
Kerry Washington so it takes place in
the 90s whole majority of it but they
want to go back and tell their stories
when they were like kids like when they
were in high school the two main
characters so they hired young people to
play young Reese Witherspoon and young
Kerry Washington and number one that
made me feel incredibly old because I'm
like you don't need to hire a [ __ ]
young person
Rhys Rhys is a kid and then I look you
know my wife's like Reese's and a kid
bro you're 49 how old you think [ __ ]
oozes and I looked and I'm like oh [ __ ]
Reese's a [ __ ] adult you do have to
get a young person to play like and not
like she's old but it's just like that's
it though the days of like remember
remember years ago when they made the
movie the babe and John Goodman played a
thirteen-year-old Babe Ruth you know and
you were like and this is without you
know CG this is gonna work you guys be
great should we find a kid no [ __ ]
get his John Goodman it was it was [ __ ]
how do I get to the babe Oh anyway
instead of casting like instead of just
putting some you know yeah or even you
like in this day and age you deh a
[ __ ] right like in the Marvel
movies like Michael Douglas look like
he's [ __ ] 40 again they didn't do
that they literally hired other
actresses to play these very famous
actresses okay so what's the age bracket
are we talking like 45 to 25 or 45 to
like 30 well I mean how old do you think
is reason carry right now I'm gonna say
mid to late 40s yeah yeah well I'd say
early to mid 40s look I can you look up
Kerry Washington and read I bet Kerry is
like 45 46 and I'd bet that Reese's like
they're both stunning like in terms of
like [ __ ] aging gracefully blah blah
blah but the point is they hired young
people to ply them and the people that
they hired to ply them are playing them
ages circa 18 to 25 ah
so in your head you're like I don't know
like the first time they did it in one
of the earlier episodes like they showed
like the breeze Witherspoon actress I
was like really like you are you sure
this is necessary like I'm sure she
could have pulled it off and stuff but
the girl who's playing young reads like
you know just definitely suggest sir she
got bigger eyes than trees doesn't stuff
and her performance is totally like you
could see like oh she [ __ ] studied
trees last night or this week they did
an episode I watched it last night
where
they had a young actress playing Kerry
Washington
how old 43 and 44 who's who Kerry's 43
43 and 44 I mean still in my head I'm
like they really could have probably had
them play themselves at a younger age
and did some of that like de-aging ship
but the actress that they pulled to play
Kerry Washington
what young Kerry Washington's character
was [ __ ] fascinating apparently she's
on that show the Amazon show with Al
Pacino hunters hunters yeah I haven't
seen the show of my wife's like how
she's on hunters it it is I didn't I
didn't watch scandal but you know I'm
[ __ ] well familiar with Kerry
Washington's performances to go like oh
that's that's pretty good Kerry
Washington if somebody did a Kerry
Washington impression yeah this girl
like I like swallowed Kerry Washington's
[ __ ] soul I've never seen anything
like it
she [ __ ] channeled her and it was
mind-bending like you had to like to in
the way
remember when like Philip Seymour
Hoffman played Capote and everybody's
like oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] really good
and so they if they give out awards for
like you sound like you you studied your
[ __ ] characters so well that you
could probably replace that person she
should get that award it was mine the
whole episode I had to go back and watch
it a second time to get the story
because the whole first time I watch it
I'm like that's an incredible facsimile
of Kerry Washington like this actress is
crushing it and then I had a discussion
with my wife if you're that actress can
you look up who that actors is if you're
that actress all right and you're in
hunter is that what the shows yeah sorry
this you're in hunters by the way there
was a stoical and somebody goes oh my
god you were great in hunters do you
feel more complimented by that than you
would if somebody said you
were amazing in [ __ ] little fires
everywhere because you were exactly like
Kerry Washington which is a higher
compliment uh you know I think I I don't
know because it's it's the same question
you have to ask everybody who's ever
been in like a biopic right like
chadwick boseman you are amazing as
James Brown like Jamie Foxx you were
amazing as Ray Charles like what does
chadwick boseman go like if you're like
you were amazing as Chawla does he go
like thank you well number one he thinks
he likes any compliment but does it mean
more that he had to create that from the
ground up he didn't use like while I was
just doing a James Brown and impression
essentially which like which would you
feel more complimented by probably the I
created something out of whole cloth as
opposed to I'm an expert forger but the
expert forger but the the other
performance is like buzziest [ __ ] like
as instantly I had to go online to be
like am I the only one and of course not
all of the internet was like it is
uncanny what she's doing and stuff and I
was wondering like her phone must be
blowing up and everybody cuz the episode
just dropped and I wonder if I was like
wow that must be amazing to be her right
now but at the same time is she like
well I mean thanks but I was just doing
Kerry Washington if you really want to
see some acting go see the other thing
or are you just happy anything like
whatever as long as you like it it's
good by me like me with the movies like
some people are like oh I [ __ ] love
you know clerks some people like I love
Yoko's I'm like well I can't figure that
out but as long as you like one of them
that makes me happy I mean I wonder if
it's the equivalent to like hey Jimmy
Hendrix you're amazing my favorite song
is all along the watchtower there's like
oh I didn't write that one like Bob
Dylan wrote that one I'm a big fan of
Purple Haze which I wrote all by myself
like do you like the cover or I don't
know if you've noticed my face but I was
just sitting there going oh what I
didn't hear the rest of that because I
was like it might be learning nobody
said Bob dunno like oh that's right that
was a Bob Dylan song but when I it's so
crazy when you say that instantly I'm
like oh it's Hendrix yeah like it is
probably his MO
recognized song is his version of that
other guy's thing right and you know at
some point as an artist you have to come
in cursive that if you're ever going to
do that kind of work right like what was
the witness's song like that I will
always love you is Dolly Parton's some
growing up to me that was the Dolly
Parton song and then one day like
Whitney Houston redefined it but Whitney
Houston like she sang song she didn't
write her own song like Sinatra so she
was never she never probably felt more
complimented for one song over the other
she's like look I just sing them all yes
somebody puts me the music and I sing a
song but it would be like like like I
wonder I wonder how I'll feel if people
like Masters of the Universe a lot like
oh you did a great job or whatever a
number one it's like what we all did a
great job together
but number two it's like wow I mean I
didn't my thing yeah I don't know like I
love what we did but I didn't come up
with he-man like a bunch of geniuses in
the 80s came up with a man and stuff
like that I I've tried to play my he-man
cards the best I could as they were
dealt but I it's such it was fun and
honestly like you want to talk about a
great performance because it captured my
imagination for hours I kept going back
to my wife being like alright what if
you were that girl and you're in the
mall and somebody comes up to you and
compared it like she was like it's
really captured your fancy I'm like it's
it's uncanny what she did but at the
same time if you were her are you like
cover song right like don't you want to
hear my original [ __ ] but you know
either way she's broke it's a bit I
suppose like hey Heath Ledger did you
win the Oscar for like Brokeback
Mountain you know you want it for the
Joker which you did amazing things with
but it's something that other people
have done before what a great analogy
that's why you do this [ __ ] show to
mark barnard and be like Batman Beyond
it's like the Joker we're talking about
music and whatever but you're absolutely
right that's true like [ __ ] and I
wonder I wonder it what I mean I wonder
what he would have felt like if you went
up to him and Heath Ledger and you were
like oh my god I loved you in Brokeback
or oh my god I loved you as the Joker
which one meant more or did they both
mean about the same like I did the same
work like I got a script I decided how
I'm gonna play this character
I brought as much of myself as I could
to it and I did the best that I could on
the day and they cut it together into
performance and I think it's pretty
great let me ask you something am i high
or is this a good conversation because I
feel like it's a really good
conversation but the same time I'm like
if you feel it's a good conversation
here's your chance to throw some tips in
the jar ladies and gentlemen because you
know just like PBS they give you a tow
package [ __ ] we can give a give a tote
bag but quality programming like what
you just saw two guys trying to figure
out which which show the actress whose
name we haven't even said jay-z the
actress is Tiffany boon incredible good
for you Tiffany boom in credible I mean
honestly like I can't I can't think of
another actor or actress who has
captured my imagination more because I
was like it is profound what a great job
she did and I'm not like might like my
wife watched every episode of scandal so
she was like this is [ __ ] nuts like
it's like they they just it's gotta be
your kid or something like that we
looked it up and it was just incredible
alright that would have been interesting
though like the the O'Shea Jackson jr.
is like oh so you're gonna play ice oh
it's your son apparently the only person
in the world who could have played Ice
Cube that well his ice cubes son in
Straight Outta Compton it's like well
[ __ ] no wonder he's got this down he's
been living with research for the last
25 years such a good point that's a
great point alright [ __ ] us let's get
into the news I know there's some
interesting [ __ ] we should look into
what mark you come from the world the
news man he's a news sound he gave all
that [ __ ] up but now in the pandemic
he's your only newsman calls on all his
old plug in contacts and his abilities
and [ __ ] to bring you the news what do
you got this broke today which have we
ever talked about
animated Disney Robin Hood movie with
the foxes and the wolves the love that
movie who ever talked about how like for
Robin Hood lived yeah walk dude for it's
ooh there's a I don't know how much time
you spent on tumblr in the days of your
youth I didn't have it all good for you
it's better than Lobby I'm not saying
that proudly I just know safer really
because much of as I encountered Robin
Hood in my elder dotage it seems to have
been this movie that for a particular
strain of young woman kind of came
adjacent to were connected to their
sexual awakening and so they who are
they into the Fox their first sure into
the Fox like into Robin it is all about
[ __ ] that Robin Hood Fox like he's
become some weird-ass sex symbol for a
particular kind of or for a bigot age of
woman who was into Disney at the time
and I don't understand why I could see
somebody being like oh I like that Robin
Hood he's so cute and stuff but not like
when I see that Fox come out the water
with that bear it makes me as wet as
they are I just want to [ __ ] a fox like
that never heard me know that's that's
it for real thing I saw that movie when
I was a kid and I wasn't like oh if I
could just get with lady Kluck Oh that'd
be amazing I loved lady Kluck that I
thought she was hysterical yeah I mean I
would have but not mean I would have
respect her I would have listened to
what she had to say yeah I wasn't even a
vegan then too so I would have been like
what a difficult relationship she'd been
like you've eaten chicken
give someone eggs I love that Robin Hood
movie why do you bring it up because
Disney they're remaking it they're
remaking it hold on
yeah a live-action live-action CG hybrid
of foxes yep why not just make [ __ ]
Robin Hood because I'm sure they're like
there's been like 19 Robin Hood movies
but only one words so it's all gonna
look like that like it's gonna be
essentially CG versions of what we know
I don't know if they're gonna go
hyperreal like don't don't lie yeah
don't do that Lion King [ __ ] where it's
just like that lion he doesn't look like
he's laughing that lion looks like a
lion like you need expressions you need
like especially you know for the foxes
and stuff yeah he was very charismatic
character Robin Hood yeah I mean they're
they're the new take is said to be
musical and again will feature the
characters as anthropomorphic this time
in a live-action CG hybrid format never
everything there's danger in the water
they were laughing they were guzzling
down you wouldn't do that anymore
No socially just it's all sound know it
sounds Jerry reachable what's his name
not Hoyt Axton he was a voice in there I
think what action is the [ __ ] for not
named Robin Hood who wrote what's his
name [ __ ] Robin Hood a little job walk
through the forest love you Roger Nelson
says name JC it's Internet fellas yeah
somebody tell us I am you know they're
gonna record new voices and all that
[ __ ] yeah soup to nuts I don't
understand why they don't just take the
old soundtrack and like animate to that
like that's what everyone loves those
voices and [ __ ] like once you stop it
the once it's no longer those voices and
it's no longer 2d animation and you're
in a real world with anthropomorphic
yeah it's not [ __ ] the Robin Hood
cartoon anymore no but if you do the old
voices then you don't get to say hey you
know who's in our show now Zac Efron is
playing Robin I know but then you also
don't have to pay that [ __ ] then
you keep the budget down and [ __ ] and at
the end of the day what are they like
nobody on tumblr is going like oh I jerk
off thinking about Zac Efron as the Fox
they're just jerking off to the Fox I'm
not sure you've seen tumblr that much I
know it's like it's nothing but pages of
I want to jerk off to Zac Efron it's all
the care a little tiny hat that's why
it's called tumblr because this tumbles
out of you wearing a shirt with no pants
oh yeah I mean look I you know I love
Jon Favreau but I did not see Lion King
just knew that wasn't my cup of tea and
not like you I'm gonna hate it I'm like
I saw a lion kick it was amazing it was
a cartoon yeah like I mean I've seen all
of them
you saw Lion King I saw a Lion King and
I saw a jungle book and of the two
heading jungle book was more successful
predominant for you there's a human
person in there who's supposed to be
human and is for human right and so much
of the emotion you're getting is from
Mowgli and not Shere Khan is why why
don't you like make them look like real
animals not give them like you know
cartoony the moment that animal starts
talking you're like come on like oh
[ __ ] reality is out the window give
them some [ __ ] morning eyes yeah whoa
yeah that's gonna be for Disney Plus oh
is it Roger Miller that's it that's it
he's the allan-a-dale in the movie he's
the you know the bird right yeah the
Troubadour there's a bard the other bird
that's not lady Kluck the guy that was
probably [ __ ] lady Kluck [ __ ] that
collect we had a goal that we posted
what was it 25 well done kids good job
everyone and we'll be matching that yes
all right so it's for Disney plus it's
for Disney Plus everything's for Disney
Plus these days I mean Artemis Fowl that
Kenneth Branagh feature film have a
discussion about this yeah I got some
theories you got some theories just go
you you run a movie studio indeed and
you make many movies mm-hmm but this is
before covet happens mm-hmm and then we
shut down all the movie theaters nobody
wants to be around each other and
everyone's scared and sooner or later
hopefully we will go back to the surface
world
[ __ ] after the army of the 12 monkeys
has been chased away and stuff and we
can re-engage with the world people are
still gonna be slow to go the multiplex
as Mark mentioned before now how you're
gonna feel like 10,000 20,000 seats at a
[ __ ] football stadium when people
like I don't want to be near that person
and [ __ ] so even when people start if
they're allowed to go back to the movies
it's gonna be a very slow process it's
not gonna be like a man
in this movie minute hundred million
dollars this weekend you ain't gonna see
that [ __ ] for a long long long [ __ ]
times going back to 70s and 80s type box
office numbers so if you're disney what
has the best chance of putting asses in
seats the day you get to turn the lights
back on after we're out of the
quarantine
Black Widow we're Artemis Fowl like if
you're disney you're sitting there gone
like [ __ ] man like how much we spend on
this [ __ ] they're like oh no 68 he's
like goddamn it man that's Walt himself
yeah god damn it he's going then we got
to spend how much more to market this
[ __ ] the like easily 40 worldwide maybe
50 and [ __ ] and and we're not even
guaranteed this is gonna break even cuz
like it ain't like the old days where
you can convince a bunch of people to go
it's gonna be an uphill battle boss [ __ ]
it put it on Disney Plus it'll make us
look like kings
like we're taking a brand new kenneth
branagh i made movie based on IP that
people [ __ ] know and [ __ ] like that
and we're saying you the disney plus
consumer you one of the how many do they
sign up 50 million or something like
that there you know ahead of their
projections we care about you and your
[ __ ] bucks so much that we're pushing
art look at this book and you know
shit's got sexy with masks is off and
[ __ ] we're pushing Artemis Fowl right
into your homes and stuff I think that's
smart play I don't think you'll ever see
that happen with a Marvel movie and
somebody bookmarked this for like
[ __ ] six months from now when they're
like Black Widow now and Disney Plus but
I don't think they're gonna play their
big money cards like think of it as
somebody sitting there playing uno you
know they just laid down a skip card by
themselves some [ __ ] time Artemis
Fowl they're like skip you watch that on
Disney Plus but when push comes to shove
man when they [ __ ] like you know
gentlemen start your engines and the
[ __ ] race begins
you better believe they're gonna be like
zip Marvel like [ __ ] they're gonna
take the big [ __ ] guns and put them
out there they're not gonna stick a
Marvel movie on Disney Plus because they
got some Marvel TV shows coming and they
got to keep them Marvel movies valuable
those movies make [ __ ] money man look
yet [ __ ] money I do think I mean and
and Disney said that this isn't going to
be the only one of our theatrical
releases to come to Disney Plus first
smart but I agree with you that I don't
think you're gonna see him of a movie in
Disney Plus but I do think you might see
a Marvel movie just for sale on [ __ ]
iTunes 25 bucks at home for Black Widow
because Disney Plus they're not making
any revenue on it like you're already
and see it they honestly the only way
they could do it and I bet you they
could I bet you this would work you put
our Black Widow on [ __ ] transactional
video and you charge a hundred dollars a
copy people would still [ __ ] buy it
dude we're crazy we're stupid think
about it he's even a pretty good deal if
you got a big household you got five
people in the house you know you're
that's what you'd spend going to see it
a movie theater get to watch in the
privacy of your own home if we all did
that
[ __ ] that would change the world I've
changed business they'd be like [ __ ]
movie theaters some of these movies for
a hundred bucks a pop it's like the
[ __ ] good old days of VHS and [ __ ]
like that I'd be amazing I hadn't even
thought of that you know I think there's
there's a there's a way well our Thomas
foul go transactional before Disney Plus
straight to digit plus there's skip and
transactional altogether well they'll
probably also do transaction I think
they will for people who don't wanna
subscribe to Disney Plus but for the but
they're using it as a like loss leader
like you better come to Disney Plus only
one reason to have it you know and I'm
sure that Disney is beginning to regret
their very early aggressive lower price
point over everybody else like they were
what $5.99 a month
6:19 like the first 10 years for seven
years and it was always they have 98
other revenue streams they don't need
this to be profitable out of the gate
and then suddenly every other one of
those revenue streams went away and this
is it right now this is their lifeline
like the I saw an article that was like
maybe Bob Iger left cuz they knew this
[ __ ] was about to happen and he was like
you know what I'm gonna go out while the
getting's good I don't want to have to
solve this problem yeah I don't want to
be the guy who is on the clock when
Corona hit and stuff I just built Disney
Plus and Disney Plus is the thing that's
booing that company
right now yeah yeah man I'm all for that
makes sense to me that's a smart play
putting on this movie had been delayed
it was already supposed to be out not
just like this summer but like last fall
selling a movie like that is when it
like that's when you're like ah man we
got to spend like almost the same amount
of money we made making this [ __ ]
thing to like sell this thing now and
stuff and I don't know who was playing
was anybody in it like you see it not a
ton of folks but like and everything
other stuff start was a kid Colin
Farrell Josh GAD and Judi Dench we're
also in it but it's a kid named
fruitiest Shaw who was playing Rodimus
foul and like he's he's as big as Daniel
Radcliffe was when he got cast there's
Harry Potter which is Harry Potter was
the lure and not whoever else is in it
right and they were hoping that I think
that Armas fell would be the beginning
of a series yeah this is big way a book
series but it's like the last of the ye
books that anybody seem to care about um
smart play I think on Disney's bad but
what the [ __ ] do I know I've I've never
made a smart [ __ ] business decision
in my life but if I was in charge of I
was playing like remember that old
Hollywood Stock Exchange game oh yes I
was playing the Hollywood Stock Exchange
I would [ __ ] that's smart play to me
it's my play all right what else we got
hey guys we are at 2,700 bucks oh my god
you guys are so [ __ ] sweet like it's
like the Muppet movie and we're trying
to like you know somebody should be
coloring in the big thermometer bulb
let's do it let's get one more person in
here
Hika Taika Waititi went on instagram
live to talk about thor ragnarok you do
love you sort of live Tweety eventi
thing with Tessa Thompson Tessa Thompson
dropped in Ruffalo dropped in just be
[ __ ] nice to have like Avengers as
friends hey guys what are you doing
today so my god nothing come and play
and you know the entire thing was just
joyous and wonderful because it's Tiger
just being tanka but he dropped a couple
of interesting
it's about dare those nuggets the first
nugget is that they're like five drafts
of the script so far maybe six drafts
and according to tyke it's so over the
top now in the very best way it makes
Ragnarok seem like a run-of-the-mill
there's a guy that's not waking up and
reading the news he's just diving into
[ __ ] love and thunder he really is
smart
this new film feels like we asked a
bunch of 10 year olds what should be in
a movie and just said yes to everything
yeah which makes me very happy
I heard star sharks star [ __ ] sharks
giant space sharks yeah
the those will be in the movie
apparently there's more about colg they
go a little deeper into core character
his character and where he's from
there's cultural specificities of
Cronin's apparently there's very
specific things in the comics about how
they procreate how far away is this
movie I think they now shifted it until
like November of 2021 doesn't he get a
big just slate pushing of everything it
might even be early 2022 well they
didn't even start shooting now I'm sorry
shooting and you know clearly won't for
a while I can't wait I love [ __ ] the
other Thor movie Ragnarok this and this
just sounds like it's gonna be batshit
wonderful yeah he said not to expect
Silver Surfer in the film nor fat Thor
won't show up but beta ray bill might
make an appearance I mean that wins
right there he don't even need him in
the whole movie
nope if his one [ __ ] shot in its beta
ray bill like for those of you who are
like why beta ray bill was a one time he
held the mole and year when what
happened to Thor
he wasn't turned into a frog was I don't
think it was frog Thor era but it was I
think like contest of the champions era
because there's there's a bit in
Ragnarok where you see all of the
champions in that Citadel and the game's
masters Palace and one of the phases is
of beta ray bill really yeah and because
it's basically like they just recreated
the the Marvel Comics
go bit that used to have the four faces
on it yeah and one of them was beta ray
bill so if he was part of that whole
arena world and you know may or may not
eventually prove himself worthy in love
and thunder seems to be a movie about
lots of people getting to be Thor let me
tell you something man like [ __ ] even
though we're in the midst of this
pandemic and [ __ ] that just made me so
happy the beta ray bill might show up in
a movie so much so that I'm like things
are gonna be alright
she gives me hope that's my go-to like
happy place I was resisting - as you
began the story I'm like yeah I [ __ ]
heard about this [ __ ] and then I
couldn't help but be warm by ya beta ray
bill I forgive my god that's a [ __ ]
that's what you I'm so easy
dammit thank God I'm not in charge of
[ __ ] I'm such a pushover all right what
else San Diego Comic Con is still
sticking to its July guns they haven't
moved it yet they have not moved it yet
what a party that's gonna be you're
gonna be able to get in the holidays
this year I assure you and not because
JJ took my [ __ ] audience it's going
to be spaced like crazy right
you just walk into everything you want a
hotel room we got 40,000 of them because
nobody's here Wow the pressures off this
year every year I feel a bit pressure
like how many people can I get in the
Hall H if it's just me late at night no
but I don't got a [ __ ] big movie
nobody gives a [ __ ] about me this year
don't matter no man are all equal in
Hall age yeah it's like how many people
showed up for you a hundred that's all
the Avengers had yeah I mean in there in
the wake of like everything else
everywhere else being canceled - pushed
or delayed or rescheduled or whatever
fingers crossed
Comic Con testing is crippling to it
like at some point the prevailing theory
that I've heard is that they're waiting
for the city of San Diego to tell them
they can't do it because the comic-con
international is like you go first
basically the city of San Diego's like
I'm [ __ ] pulling this plug ain't
getting a whole internet philanderers
jumping on my dick no way and I think
some of that is because unless if the
city forces them to cancel then they
don't have to refund the money's for
like table reservations
and exhibitor booths and all that stuff
it's force majeure Oh kind of like South
by Southwest when Austin was like you
can't have this and South by Southwest
was like not our fault he didn't cancel
it they made us cancel it so I think
that might be a bit of a financial
decision I don't know that's a theory
I'm not saying it's fact sorry mark do
we have an economy left after all this
sure I mean I thought I thought it all
fell apart yeah pretty much it's we're
almost in Bartertown not here though
[ __ ] good folks have been donating to
the scum and villainy Cantina your home
away from home
home of fat man beyond me and Mark
matching what you've donated what have
they donated JC we are just shy of 3,000
get back to a shot of us what the [ __ ]
man we donate muster said we would so we
will donate all right what's next make
it [ __ ] fast George Miller yield
Grand Master George Miller who almost
made a Justice League movie years ago
major men of course gave his fury road
yeah the writer strike of its 2008 also
responsible for the last segment of The
Twilight Zone movie that's right the
John Lithgow who's a man on the wing in
this plane
yeah the nightmare at 20,000 feet he is
preparing and gearing up for a furiosa
prequel to Mad Max fury road yeah how
you feel about that though it's mid Sam
and he's a genius it's [ __ ] him and
that character I mean that entire me is
gonna be her he's not gonna be here
because it's a prequel so they're
starting to cast around you know they
should get who should they that girl who
played young Kerry Washington she was
amazing if she could do for Vogue and
Charlize but she did for Kerry
Washington there's your new furiosa
what's her name again boom something
boom something boon Tiffany boon Tiffany
boom that's that right we got it
Tiffany boon hire her to play everybody
she was that good if you don't believe
me you go watch the latest episode
of little fires everywhere brought to
you by Lulu alright so he's he's
starting to meet with actresses at this
point virtually and remotely but a Jody
comer who's a who won I want to say is a
Golden Globe but maybe even an Emmy for
killing Eve villanelle and killing Eve
she's in the running to play young
furiosa and now according to Variety and
you're Taylor joy who was in the New
Mutants playing Illyana Rasputin
oh she's yeah magic or what it was that
girl they want to play young Charlize
Theron yeah yeah I proved were you
asking for my approval I was yes you
have my blessing can I go back real
quick a little fires we blew the other
girls so much the other girl who does
Reese Witherspoon she doesn't get a good
job - yeah but Kerry Washington
Tiffany Boone just sublime casters
everything she should play the Silver
Surfer and Galactus when they bring into
the Marvel movies I'm on board for that
apparently George Miller wants Richard
Madden from from Game of Thrones mm-hmm
don't we all the north I want Richard
men would want to see he was the king of
North he played a Rob stark the first
king of the north and that [ __ ] red
wedding guy yeah he was such a good
character man I mean that episode is
mind-bending and [ __ ] and I'm glad it
exists but it was like 2:00 in the
morning and I was like you know what
like I watched three of these I'm just
gonna watch a little bit more of this
one and then it's almost over I watched
this then I'll go to bed and they killed
everybody I loved in that show no it's
like what the [ __ ] I haven't slept good
ever again it was terrifying watching
him die that [ __ ] sucked man worse
watching him kill his wife yeah remember
that [ __ ] couple she was the nurse and
[ __ ] like you know [ __ ] he was the
king and [ __ ] and they wound up like
together an unlikely couple of [ __ ] and
then that [ __ ] was like oh god
still one of the most horrifying things
I've ever seen in my life real or unreal
god I I don't I don't know if I'm never
gonna do a game of thrones rewatch only
because I know where I've eventually I'm
gonna get to I kind of want to now's the
time oh my god if you ever thought about
it only [ __ ] I'm coming to the end of
the Battlestar podcast we were doing the
third season finale next Friday and then
season four is it you [ __ ] me there were
only four seasons that shows about and
then you're done and then we're done
yeah what we talk about old school
battle story go back to the 70s yeah
who's still alive that I can talk to see
if you get Lorne Greene to come on the
show
come on buddy he's dead I mean he was on
bonanza for Christ sakes
we miss you Lorne but yeah remember he
was a voice too was he the voice of
mutual of Omaha's Wild King has lured
Lauren green he had a very commanding
voice I think Dirk Benedict is still
kicking around so I can talk to Dirk
about it hey go bring him I got one get
the guy who played LT boomer who else
Richard Hatch's around what are you
talking about your dad passed away what
he was on that show he was he was on
both shows yeah I passed away I want to
say like four or five years ago between
then and now Richard Hatch's died sorry
[ __ ] Kovac he didn't die from this he
did not know unless that passed me I
loved when he was on that show so [ __ ]
it and he was he was he carried the
torch for og battle store like he wrote
comic books about it he did hard yeah as
he wanted he wanted to be involved with
the reboot and he was like actively
against it like campaigning against Ron
Moore's version of it was he really he
hated the idea of it and then they saw
it brought him in he saw it it was like
I'm sorry this is actually pretty good I
didn't I didn't I didn't know what they
were doing now that I see it I recant
all of my previous criticisms of it and
they invited him on this Tom Zarek it's
that [ __ ] simple apparently I'm gonna
attack the [ __ ] out of the next Ron
Moore Show in advance of it airing and
then the moment it's on I'm gonna be
like this is pretty good you know what I
mean what's wrong get me a [ __ ]
invite into
that show then I'm gonna call Damon
Lindelof and be like I need a mask
Watchmen sucked actually no very good
[ __ ] Watchmen so good I was just
talking about with somebody else the
other day man I went back I think I said
this last week I went back and I just
started watching my favorite moments and
[ __ ]
oh so [ __ ] good and I'm so I don't
know him I interviewed him once Damon
and it sounds like [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
me what do I know but I'm so proud of
him for like now we're done don't want
to do any more amazing restraint dude
had a story wanted to tell it against
all [ __ ] odds told it and it's one of
the greatest stories ever told and he's
like makes so much sense to me John and
makes up for that [ __ ] aliens movie
what was it called yeah it wasn't great
not as fun well you know what whatever
doesn't matter all is forgiven he can
[ __ ] you know strike me with a car he
can call on me give me [ __ ] kovat and
I'd be like worth it he gave us that
Bloxom series one of my favorite things
in the last like three or four days is
the what seemed to have been like out of
nowhere but I totally get it the sharing
of audience reactions to moments from
Avengers endgame yes which was just like
I didn't expect it in my timeline but
then suddenly it's like joy the [ __ ]
hammer and the crowd going nuts and then
on your left the crowd going nuts yes
the hammer here in the crowd go crazy
was awesome when we were on the road
with reboot Roadshow I had Josh dr. Josh
Roush shoot the audience at a couple
shows for that exact reason because I'm
like like this is wonderful and I'll
remember it always but I want a [ __ ]
record of this more importantly I want a
record in case anyone has ever liked
this movie ain't [ __ ] funny or they
shout out one part I could literally
pull an audience clip of people [ __ ]
dying hysterical and billing one man's
opinion
but it's so gratifying to hear that on
my own stuff when I saw those clips on
Twitter it
it made me bubbly like [ __ ] as
watching the waves of acknowledgement
like as Mullen or even move
and then takes off that got its own like
Wow
and then the moment [ __ ] it hits fan OHS
then comes back and they reveal cap it
was perhaps the loudest sound I've ever
heard come out of my phone it's so
[ __ ] joyous and it reminded me of
when we were all allowed to go to the
movies and sit around each other and
scream and spit [ __ ] spittle at the
guy in front and the lady behind ya as
it comes out of your mouth and [ __ ] man
oh man yeah those are fun Clips those
are amazing let's say next story Ryan
Reynolds sorry who was that I'm
unfamiliar with his work he was in two
guys a girl and a pizza place oh my god
I remember seeing that pilot did
anything he's finally getting work he's
finally getting see was the best part of
that show doesn't mean the pizza place I
mean let's be honest I where he loves
pizza wish him well I hope that kid
catches on yeah what is all Deadpool up
to old Deadpool is is in talks to star
in and produce a live-action feature
adaptation of Dragon's Lair did you ever
play Dragon's Lair oh the video games a
youngster did well did I ever hear ask
me did I ever pay for Dragon's Lair yes
do I feel I ever played Dragon's Lair no
it was the biggest scam on the planet
you play cost like a [ __ ] buck and
then it was a cartoon that did what it
wanted to do so you move a joystick and
you were like now I'm watching a cartoon
it was fun but yeah I remember being tad
was like the first laserdisc video game
yes because all the animation was done
by Don Bluth Oh gorgeous and lovely but
it was all like timing based so like
your hero would be like I'm walking down
this corridor and if you press this
button at just the right time he would
duck his arrows flame that his head and
if he didn't you just died and if you
didn't have the timing perfect there's
no way to do anything in that game
besides watch this is gorgeous animation
that I paid a lot of money to watch but
that's the thing is like every game is a
[ __ ] quarter that game is a buck or
more and like it lasted 12 seconds and
you were like look it's pretty but tired
of seeing that dude with his skull and
[ __ ]
spend five dollars and see an actual
full and animated movie as the most of
the $500 it's gonna cost me to finish
this game I'll be honest with you though
the idea of him and Dragon's Lair movie
yeah I'm there yeah I make make sense I
could see it like it's gonna have a
sense of humor too what happened with
this movie where he's the guy in a
videogame that ever come out free fire
yeah well it's a free guy or what really
free guy if I was a it didn't come out
right
didn't come out it was supposed to come
out this summer it looked like it was
gonna make a lot of money man I felt
like that was gonna be a hit I was like
Jesus that looks entertaing so let's be
out in July and I think everything else
is new plus could entirely be Wow good
for Ryan Reynolds he continues to work
he does man he's he's putting [ __ ]
together nice kid Canadian kid they say
ya know and he was just shooting a
Netflix action movie with with Dwayne
Johnson and gal gadot called red notice
which I'm sure it has stopped production
a little because everything has he
wasn't he in a Netflix movie for Michael
Bay yes six underground which is weird
have you've seen it I did I saw it
because the two guys - the executive
producers on the Continental where Rhett
Reese and Paul Wernick loved guys we've
had a mana Babylon on geeking out we
should have him on the show there Greg
dudes wonderful totally good but they
wrote that movie for Michael Bay and
they were like you should watch it it's
awful and I did and they write the only
honestly I had no interest and not
because I'm better than it I'm just like
there's a lot of [ __ ] to watch but you
actually put it on my radar by saying
those dudes wrote it even though you're
saying those dudes are like [ __ ] that
movie
well because it's it's the full Bay it's
as Bay as base things to get and that's
a lot
yeah might be it's a lot of Bay
commitment I mean he does what he does
he does very well but what he does is
for the vast majority of people that
don't ever really seem to be me I try I
always go willingly but then I'm like no
I was a bayen
I mean my car Megaton yeah I do like
Armageddon I like I you know the
Transformers movie I didn't go for still
tough for me the first movie that made
me feel like an old man I'm like who's
fighting who there's all this metal yeah
they're all sharp and jagged II and I
just want to go home this seems hurdy
but yeah I mean clearly he knows what
he's [ __ ] doing that bad boys picture
made a lot of money it did he didn't
direct that one though what yeah you
need to the third one bad boys for life
who did Craig Brewer I believe the guy
did have someone flow and is doing
coming to America that's you're not
right there's no way that's right
Michael Bay had to have made bad boys 3
I don't believe you did somebody look it
up
who did it ain't Craig Brewer Craig
Brewer did you know my name is dolomite
dolomite is my name and he's doing the
coming to America who directed that who
point is it's not Michael Bay did he
produce it probably I'm sure he got a
tape how did he let that go that's his
franchise right didn't he do the first
two you're the first two Bruckheimer
produced but it was not Michael Bay I
would have some thank God you two I'm
learning all sorts important [ __ ] with a
gun to my head I would have been like
Michael Bay [ __ ] taking me out but
yeah yeah yeah Michael Bay I did suffer
in the past I've liked but the less
restrained he gets the more BAE he goes
the less patience I have and so yeah six
feet underground or six underground is
just it's all the time the loudest movie
you will ever watch even if it's me lots
explosions yeah but even if they do on
silent like it's just so loud and at the
end I want a big explosion alright next
story how obsessive of a comic book
collector have you ever been at the
height of your collectivity I had a
giant-sized
man annual but you know pricey book back
will you a complete run kind of guy
only with books that I what not like you
know I'm good on Golden Age like I only
modern comics all the minor comics
Sotheby's is is offering a DC complete
collection a guy named Ian Levine mmm
which has every comic book released by
American publisher DC Comics from 1935
to 2014 including complete runs of
Superman Batman action comics and
Detective Comics Wow so wait this person
one person has been collecting since the
30s no he started collecting I want to
say in like the 80s but just started a
massive collection started going
backwards started going forwards like
and then was broken by the new 52 gonna
buy it I know rock this I'm out alright
so how am I starting bids hundred
dollars take it all off your hands right
now for $100 I'm gonna get like a
million for Action Comics number one let
me give you 100 bucks and see if you
wanna break that one book out go ahead I
don't care yeah
they don't say precisely what the
opening bid is going to be but given
that Action Comics number one is a
million dollar book who's buying this
you'd think um who's got that kind of
money especially right now Nicolas Cage
not anymore
[ __ ] mortgage to his teeth yeah
I think the days of buying overpriced
comic books might be behind the cage I
mean I I wonder if this is the kind of
thing that like nobody buys right now I
just but like he will then put on alone
to like the Smithsonian or to some like
comic book art museum or whatever but
yeah but not like Johnny Depp maybe but
no cuz he's also a little bit mortgaged
to the teeth Clooney could perhaps sell
his Lake Como mansion if he really likes
comic books he's like I had a dalliance
with comic books it was called Batman
and Robin you know who buys this [ __ ]
thing
Bezos like it's got to be somebody like
that it's got him even he can't do it
right
now you buy this thing right now the
whole world's gonna be like you selfish
prick you're the new Hitler why didn't
you give that money to the cause
guys it anonymously and then in like ten
years we'll reveal that he's the dude
who bought it
I mean maybe look I God god bless him I
hope they make all the money in the
world that's an impressive collection
though it's nuts
like I I love things I just want to find
out what broke that person why did they
like after all that time all those books
and that's you know you're talking about
warehouses to store that many [ __ ]
comic books 40,000 books what was the
breaking point yeah it's just like yeah
you know I'm bored of this [ __ ] or was
it like they rebooted the entire
universe again and I just couldn't
handle it I bet you that like 2014 is
about when the new 52 started so he was
just like no you know what no I had a
good run
I'm finished I had a complete run one
day son B's today not another [ __ ]
comic book that was six years ago that
person stuff yeah yeah I don't know if
now is the right time but I guess that
was kind of pre schedule then maybe I'm
wrong maybe the like look people are
indoors they got plenty time to [ __ ]
bid and [ __ ] like that like as awful as
the world maybe they were still gonna be
the 1% the idle rich the [ __ ] Saudi
prince who loves everything American and
it's like yeah I got this done speaking
of American riches how we doing JC
what's our tote board say we are at
three thousand three hundred sixty nine
eighty eight cheese Wow Wow we're gonna
be broke the last is a bit of a downer
you know we know we have too much
Downers outside the damage or this place
I know that we have to mark the passing
of a legend Mort Drucker this is sad
well I mean I mean yes it's all death is
sad thankfully it doesn't seem like he
passed from coronavirus no he did not he
died at 90
on 91 at the end of the day huge bucket
of win as we say on Hollywood babble-on
what a massive life it's a shame that
you had to die it's a shame anyone had
to die but 91 is [ __ ] great yeah you
want to talk about influential you want
to talk about talent you talked to
almost any funny person of a certain age
they all read Mad Magazine when they
were kids
you talk to people who aren't funny for
a living they read Mad Magazine - and so
you constantly interacted with the
artwork of Mort Drucker who could
capture famous people incredibly well
was a just an incredible incredible
artist who worked for them for decades
right yeah like he got he stole movie
posters didn't he do the poster for
American Graffiti mm-hmm that's Mort
Drucker as well if you ever saw the
American Graffiti poster you're sitting
there going what's American Graffiti the
guy who made Star Wars made other movies
okay and they made this picture called
American Graffiti and more chugger did
the poster yeah like he he spent three
years early in his career with DC Comics
and then left in the 50s to do freelance
and in 56 he pitched his work to Mad
Magazine and got his first gig and from
then he did 300 more issues Oh huge
bucket a win as we sail because of him
and his style and his skill that they
began to do more of the movie and TV
satires it began to do like it was that
was his bread and butter and they were
so successful David it's true because in
the beginning they didn't do like TV and
movies like you know classic Matt of my
era of the 70s is very much like you
know it opens with a TV parody and it
closes with a movie parody or vice versa
and stuff but in the beginning they
didn't do that and I guess you're right
he gave them a strong muscle with like
well Mort can draw anything [ __ ]
let's do mash and caught mush I mean you
know Mort was talented the writers but
yeah I mean and I think that that he was
not just an excellent caricaturist but
he was a legit cartoonist and so could
not just do the likenesses amazingly
well but could do the actual hard work
of telling story on the page
he was he was the first winner of the
National cartoonist society Medal of
Honor award in 2015 he was cartoonist of
the year in 1987 cartoonist of the year
or tunas of the Year I mean he had a a
massive life and left a massive legacy
behind him and his art touched I mean at
least mine like a big mad guy and stuff
like that I was ingesting that dudes are
dead dude as a rock star name like you
know there are people from your
childhood whose names loom large even
though like most of the world don't
[ __ ] know who they aren't stuff but
as a little kid reading the credits you
know of the departing of idiots or
whatever they wrote in their [ __ ] you
know masthead or whatever you'd see his
name so he was a rock star name to me
and stuff 91 91 so a good life
what a great life man what a great run
and he got out you know the old
fashioned way just died of natural
causes right yeah now his apparently his
last words at least to a fella named you
got more Drucker's last words yeah Sue's
friend cartoonist John Reiner last words
were I'm the luckiest man I've had a
wonderful life [ __ ] god damn it I want
to go out like that I want to have
enough grace to be that person man be
like had a great time I mean I was when
I was like almost I would die from the
heart attack but I don't know if I could
be that guy at the [ __ ] very end
Ralph Garman his dad passed away a
couple months ago and he said when his
dad told him that like you know he went
to he had a fall and he went to the
hospital and Ralph's like are you okay
and he's like yeah everything's fine
with the fall like I didn't break
anything it's just this tumor and he had
like brain cancer or something like that
but with Ralph's went to see him and he
was like broken up and dad bullion and
he said that his dad said I had a great
life like what a great time you know and
like to be that person you keep that
perspective oh wow that's I mean look I
love the man's work when I was a kid
I respect the man's work as an adult but
that was my favorite part of the Mort
Drucker story was hearing that when he
[ __ ] checked out he was content he
deserved that very that much he made so
many people happy in his life you know
nobody there's no good way out but if
you could go out like that
and the luckiest man I've had an amazing
life that's great what a beautiful way
to end the show are we doing Q&A s I
mean how much money you got my lawyers
keep doing a show like 10 grand and [ __ ]
like that
yeah I mean let's step livelier uh we
got do we have questions okay okay what
streaming services library do you like
the most
what streaming services library do I
like the most currently I'm in a [ __ ]
deep relationship with Disney Plus
because I'm watching all the Simpsons
and I could have done that on other apps
but now they're all here with Disney
plus and under one roof and I like it I
like their deep catalogue I think it's
easy to use the interface is great and
stuff but I love that it'll just keep
planks in place Simpsons why fall asleep
and keeps going I wake up in a whole
season is past and [ __ ] so that's the
one I'm been spending the most time with
however little fires everywhere is on
Hulu and that's will you'll see the
performance of a lifetime by Tiffany
boon what about you I I think I'm I'm
still a Netflix kid just because the
last couple of things that I've been
watching like I just started watching
lock-and-key which I that was it for so
far like three episodes in and I kind of
liked it as a comic book first yeah I
was by Joe Hill and uh Gabriel Rodriguez
I think the artist name is Joe Hill is
baby Stephen King yes Stephen King the
Stephen King jr. what is his name joking
I believe is given name is Joe King Joe
King funny did I just didn't they do
that in the comics like they must have
done that
Joker and I'm like oh my god we just
discovered something as oldest [ __ ] Joe
why'd he go he'll because just to
distance from dad to attempt to have his
own to be his own man and very much is
that I mean these guys own I didn't he's
gonna hold Meister bestsellers all under
his own name
Wow man it runs in the family so yeah I
think it's I'm still in a Netflix tone I
think who lose original programming is
pretty great and I think it's maybe even
a little bit better at least the stuff
that I'm watching then the the Netflix
stuff because as much as I was
fascinated by Tiger King it's a bit
sloppy his documentary isn't really I
think so I was glad as as long as it was
I mean what I had other respect for was
just when they ended they're about to
end every episode they're like oh by the
way this [ __ ] up shits about to happen
you're like well I got to watch the next
[ __ ] show yeah I mean I think there's
there's some there's some specious
reporting especially on Carroll Baskin
who seems to be portrayed far shadier
than any facts anybody has can bring to
bear which is her husband died under
mysterious circumstances but no the show
says she killed him and they don't
actually have any proof well I got the
show didn't say that the show just the
show this is what all those other people
in the and her spheres said that show
they're supporting the idea that Joe
exotic offers which is Joe believes that
he killed her but he wasn't the only one
there were a bunch of people that were
alike including that lawyer guy who was
her dead husband's lawyer who's like I'm
not at liberty to say but I have my own
ideas like he it wasn't just Joe exotic
other people suggested it but I never
honestly got the impression that the
show said oh we think she's guilty they
just kind of said here's what this
person says here's what this person
here's that what's your take on it do
you think she she's not guilty i I don't
know but like the 19 people saying that
she is even though none of them have any
proof but with only herself to say I
didn't kill my husband feels like it's
Lobster and her current husband he's her
husband like it's it's it's we're making
we've decided that Carol Baskin is going
to be the bad guy
and so we will just that curiosity
though what if she well she she very
well might they're looking into that
story now like they're getting tips the
guy said the sheriff is getting like six
tips a day about you know the missing
husband and stuff I don't know I'm
certainly like I don't I didn't feel I
was manipulated by the show but I also
didn't feel like the show was like oh
she's guilty but they were like let's
put the camera on this person over here
is telling this very interesting story
like they literally sidestep their own
narrative for a whole episode just to do
like what if right I I was never as
invested in that show as I was in the
trailer for that show which is like
it's just literally just watching it and
it's here's this guy who owns a zoo also
super gay also might have killed a lady
also like it's just it's it's unspooling
every twist in the two and a half
minutes that commercial right and then
it kept waiting for like a different
thing that I hadn't heard and it's like
oh no this is all really fascinating
like I kind of want to live in the weird
sex cult of this other dude who's just
like I also do think this guy getting
laid and feeling the same type of [ __ ]
that that guy does but here's my 15
common-law wives who were all cool with
this what go into that story though it
makes me feel like I really should have
owned an elephant in this life watching
him walking that elephant into the water
and [ __ ] just like wow yeah like it's
fascinating but but did you ever listen
to - there was a podcast called s Tom
mm-hmm it came from the same people who
did serial and it's similar in its the
like kind of small town America
with this incredibly colorful dude who
has his own perspectives on the world
but the way that keeps working is every
episode they would reveal some different
fundamentally paradigm-shifting fact
about this guy you're like oh this and
oh [ __ ] this and oh wait he did what
where Tiger King just kept on Balin oh
he's weird and like this kind of weird
right and still weird and like why are
these people being with him because he's
like magnetic weird I could just I was
waiting for that massive turn like if
they saved that he was in
spoilers that he was in jail until like
episode of for like oh [ __ ] wait what no
and they end episode 1 with I'm Joe
exotic and I'm in jail why did you blow
that spoilers but neither here nor there
I watched all of it and I get it and
yeah it's just I've been I've been in a
Netflix hole for a while
sounds so [ __ ] sexy and filthy things
I've been in the Netflix hole Netflix
and chill and every time I hear that it
makes you hard yeah Pavlovian response
um so yes that's that's my streaming
network of choice at the moment there it
is man you got an answer out of us you
gave us a question we gave you a [ __ ]
answer I imagine we're gonna do this
next week I see no reason not to
we'll be back there'll be more news
maybe ok go try to earn some money so we
could [ __ ] pay our half of the bill
something I cop it's easy for all you
guys you gave little pieces we have to
match that so we're having a fundraiser
next week for me and Mark yes to pay for
this week's magic magic fundraiser you
have a good time kids I know I did and I
didn't know I was being honest I was
like man I [ __ ] fuel unproductive but
I'm so glad I came out and stuff if
you're into watching people do [ __ ]
online which is about the only game in
town right now I will what am i doing
tomorrow I'm playing poker in the
morning with Ben Affleck and Jason Mewes
and a host of very famous people for
charity all proceeds going to feeding
America I think it's called you could
watch that it begins at 11:00 a.m. and I
think I'm gonna go be on Chris Jericho's
live stream tomorrow night this is this
is what the entertainment biz is now
it's just a bunch of people jumping on
everybody's live streams and stuff so
yeah I'll be I'll be doing that where
can they see you you see me here next
Friday and that Battlestar Galactica
continues - are you doing that are you
doing it socially distance we are doing
it we're zooming it yeah I bought myself
a microphone for my house and
I'm in the modern podcasting world this
he's gone pro I know I got something I
got some [ __ ] when I left you us but
alert now I am the minister but uh but
yeah that is that it's still going great
guns sci-fi is doing a Battlestar
Galactica marathon starting I think
April 20th for three days they're
showing every episode of Battlestar
including the miniseries including the
webisodes including a two-hour movie
they did call the plan Tricia Helfer is
is hosting that she's hosting to doing
the wraparound I was doing all the
wraparound she's interviewing a bunch of
people from the cast she's intrigued me
about the podcast on that thing during
the brought fear in the brothers during
the book on sci-fi
I'm sorry I don't the [ __ ] Internet
son that's legit like television TV
shooting from my house that's pretty
[ __ ] though yeah nice to be a fan and
then to aggregate into the actual
[ __ ] world the craziest part of it
was that one thing we got to do before
the the [ __ ] quarantine shut us down
was we got to do a live read of the very
first episode of Battlestar 33 and we
got as many members of the cast as were
in Los Angeles or would be to come to
Trish's house and I'll sit down with
microphones and read through the script
so we got edward james olmos and jamie
bamber and Katee Sackhoff and tricia
naturally in James Calais and Michael
trucco and yeah that's almost everybody
it's almost everybody Wow
I mean a couple people who weren't in
the the first season but it would
eventually come in later like Rekha
Sharma was there truco like I said was
there
Debbie Woodside who was on Lucifer with
Tricia but it's just a [ __ ] fan
showed up and read some stuff I read all
of the screen direction for it all I
mean recorded for a podcast and so that
is gonna drop I think during the the
marathon everyone will be able to hear
everybody be able to hear well who does
Tricia play in Lucifer she played
Lucifer's mother she played yes who was
just ever referred to his mom but uh but
yes she's the mother I was losing
forever mother um good God had a wife in
that show in that particular show yes
God who gave birth to everything had a
wife who also gave birth through
everything and nobody got mad at that
show the amount of [ __ ] that they get
away with
is legit contrary I mean believe me I'm
not like trying to store any trouble but
by god I made dog mine we couldn't open
our mail for like a year there they make
a movie where a TV show with a like God
was married and I've does the first time
here and about it yeah good for them
they're flying under the radar people
like that loose for sure they really do
they really do but yeah it was it was
the best time I'd ever had as a nerd is
like you know I watched the I love the
show as a fan when it first came on I
started covering the show DW as she's
like a job and then to find myself in a
room with like almost the entire [ __ ]
cast of that show as they're reading an
episode of their show from their scripts
and like flubbing lines occasionally and
like doing weird like it was in Kherson
something you never would have seen
they'd only say frack and I'll show and
they would yeah and like all the real
world they could be like [ __ ] with a
little bit of wine and it was uh it was
astounding I told them I was like this
is the most surreal thing that I've ever
been a part of and I've done some
surreal [ __ ] that's [ __ ] dope but
yeah when are they hearing it stop it
soon it's dropping on the 20th of April
I think in conjunction with this
marathon that they're doing remind me
when this show is over to share a
Battlestar Gallactica thing with you
that ties into stuff that's coming okay
you'll like this excellent I don't have
to get you as a [ __ ] guest on the
podcast in a heartbeat before we're done
I would I would love to you know let me
check my schedule but very busy mark
folks did you have a good time this
evening that's what I do it for and to
not have it is it's like [ __ ]
drowning I guess makes no sense yes
thank you for hanging out with us
tonight thank you for donating to the
scum and villainy Cantina man here in
Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard JC and
Jen heroically keeping this [ __ ] open
man even though it's eaten away all
their [ __ ] savings and stuff just so
we all have a place to hang out when
this is all over and it will be over
ladies
and keep hope as they say so say we all
as Mark and his friends what are they
say on the [ __ ] Mandalorian man this
is the way [ __ ] I want nuts for the
first time they said that when they're
like this is the way I was like yeah
[ __ ] that shows good this is a way
waited to use it and let's get a Clapton
crossover the mandalorian playing
singing a masking [ __ ] thanks for
hanging out with those folks don't
forget wash your hands
wear gloves when you go out in public
wear a mask you know who's got him Damon
Lindelof Damon is rich so he's got lots
of those man hit him up I'm sure he'll
send you one don't forget to be kind to
everyone it's tough sometimes a
quarantine particularly when you're
stuck in the same dueling or stuck in
the same zoom or whatever the [ __ ]
just remember civility civility always
it's chaos be kind civility now that's
right it's chaos be kind and when you're
on the zoom remember other people can
see you so like even if you know if
you're not wearing pants don't stand up
don't take a computer with you like Oh
nobody's would remember we're all
watching now probably best to wear pants
always if you're gonna rock a zoom man
you see that one zoom with a lady like
took it into the bathroom go Jennifer
no did ya like buggin how did you not
and it was even like maybe if you put it
on the sink then people be like well I
think she's taking a whiz but she
literally put it on the ground and then
drop drawer drop trou in front of the
camera spellbinding remember when that
happened and like it was all over the
Internet it seems like a thousand years
ago last week really last week nuts
so many things and nothing has happened
we're going through the weirdest time of
our lives together ladies a gentleman
like Mark said it's traumatic so adjust
accordingly thanks for hanging out with
us we'll be back next week hopefully
there'll be some [ __ ] news to share or
we'll get into the commentaries we could
do that that's right maybe next week we
got to [ __ ] the news maybe we gather and
we dive right into the dark night
commentary track
[ __ ] yeah they do is we put a laptop
here and you and me are looking at it
with the sound off and we'll let them
sync up and [ __ ] but then the rest of
the time it's just us talking and what
talking and look and talking and looking
hell yeah
or maybe a big TV over there so we could
just keep looking straight past this
[ __ ] right but yeah we'll figure JC
bring in a contractor we need to hang a
monitor we just made you 6,000 dollars
spend it on some refurbishment surprise
thank you for being here we'll see ya
next weekend hopefully on Friday man
enjoy the rest of your Friday night
enjoy your weekend happy Easter this
weekend for those of you who are into
that sort of thing or have kids and
whatnot if you're looking for Easter
movie Mallrats counts they beat up the
Easter Bunny totally does there's a
bunny in it there's a bunny in it there
it is and speaking of mall rats on 4/20
I'm doing one of those watch alone
parties with focus I think is doing it
and stuff but I don't think that's on
video I think I'm literally just
tweeting alone and I don't know I'll
find out more details but there's
details somewhere online if you go to my
Instagram or something like that
420 man very memorable day I might smoke
weed that day what I mean but then again
this has been April of 2020 it's been
420 all month oh my god he's right I
just blew my [ __ ] mind
I don't think about that the whole ride
home thanks for hanging out ladies and
gentleman thanks for donating to the
scum and villainy Cantina right here in
Hollywood and stuff
enjoy your weekends I hold on in my head
is your joy ladies generally have a good
time today we can't do this show without
the man in my left it's like we're
literally going like
oh hey happy birthday to you having
people do you happy birthday dear mark
mark I literally had to go through all
that for like which letter comes after J
I don't know ABCD efg hijk yeah yeah and
so give it up for the man to my left
without whom there's no show mr. mark
[ __ ] Bernardo thank you and that there
am i back on mental script is fat man
beyond for this week I'm Kevin Smith and
I'm mark barnard
tune in next time same fat time same fat
channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith this is the way
you